enable hand input visual helpers in the
control section i don't need help
i finished the mission i i might need
some help nah you're good you're ready
fine okay fine
um
direct link to ground base researchers
is nice do you think we're gonna like
call back to earth and realize that
we're the only two humans left alive um
yeah probably
or they're not answering the phone
because they don't want to hear from us
idiots and this was the only solution to
get us off the planet the station was
empty
it was and there was blood which was
strange that's true
is it something we must assemble the
tower from its stowed configuration and
calibrate each antenna oh no
i don't know what that means i'm just
gonna go for it i think it means we
gotta go outside gab
that's fine we're good at that now
whoosh
oh i was right there
oh
i'm right there you got
oh minty fresh
this feels inappropriate all right
this is the hr manual yeah
uh
go ahead
yeah lay it on me i'm gonna close my
eyes so i can absorb the information
better uh
well you got one
tv
two tv three tv for tv
oh a gamer set up love it there's a
dildo
a huge gamer set up extendable
uh there's some bowls
and a penis
that's all says captain that's all it
says
over and out
space lingo i don't understand it
man we should have took in that train
and oh oh this seems important
what do you do don't crush me with that
ultrasound i don't know
oh it doesn't
and i'm trying to get out for money
there's a direct cable red cables in all
right blue cable oh sorry
[Music]
whip it in like one of those uh knife on
a string people on dick dock
oh you ever see
i don't know what they are they got a
knife on a string
stringer
oh
okay now find the frequency oh what
find a freak how did you glean all of
that from the tvs in the dildos i'm a
gamer okay look at that you see that all
right
oh
right there captain oh yeah
building a signal portfolio oh
well that was actually much easier than
i thought it would be
yeah thanks for all the help
hey i did stuff
i'm out of here please don't be open
space please don't be open
what is all these about oh that can be
open space oh [ __ ] oh god
okay what does this do what does this do
what am i doing what am i doing
i don't know oh we gotta bring the thing
we gotta i gotta go back
i'll be back captain
okay i'm
which way is earth
which is kentucky
yeah
it makes sense we're all from kentucky
i'm bringing this thing captain
oh man
oh it's heavy
oh yeah
it's okay you can't dislocate your
shoulders in space
oh my fat ass
oh
god why am i getting wedged right there
all right i'm gonna get behind it and
push it
come back
captain
stop
i don't believe i don't believe i don't
believe isaac's stupid name i don't
believe
why he's not inscribable i don't know
captain i don't know
oh
which hand is witch
oh man i really should have been on the
other side of this
okay i'm getting on the other side of
this because i cannot stand all right i
was working on it captain
i was working on it and i came from deep
space to do your job for you
okay okay
the blue gotta go in okay
okay
and it goes oh my god oh my god
and uh
i got this
i'm so good at learning do the knife
thing
knife string knife string
did it work i've lost the gift it was a
one-time tick-tock only
just one viral tick-tock
that's all you need it was going in oh
oh thank you it's all right captain look
i'll uh i'll calibrate it
actually no calibrate it see what's up
wait which way is down what's with this
lever here i think you're gonna have to
turn something after you do that
it's like you gotta use them in tandem
right
what am i doing why is space open to me
now i gotta move this someplace right we
gotta move it up or down or is oh oh oh
this is the thing we move yeah yeah i
see if i can you two in tandem you turn
one and then you turn the other right
i'm rotating okay
kind of
i'm rotating is that cleaning the signal
up
no
no no it must be in this box
wait unplug what's plugged and re-plug
this plug
it won't re-unplug captain it's
unplugged you're the captain
i'm sorry i was talking to myself
in space no one can hear you think
i love when captain first doing the
third person oh god
oh why is everything open okay here
slam that in okay watch this
wow
wait there's no power okay
you got to push the thing into place
okay you're right antenna over you're
right
you're right you are you right you might
be right
[Music]
it's still so backwards for me i still
cannot
oh
god why would you do that
okay maybe you orient yourself that's
okay i got it and slam okay she's in
place
oh wait no that's a self-powering cycle
this don't work we didn't create
perpetual energy here captain oh damn it
i thought that's why we were sent up
here
yeah yeah that's what they told us about
the gerbils and this whatnot then what
does that plug into
um
uh
i don't know but try the other one back
again because uh now i'm thinking that
the power would be sent across oh there
you go
so much power all right i'm swing swung
and back in here
where's the signal
where's the signal find it have it taste
it love it
okay i think you might have to twisty
the the doodad oh right right i'll be
right on it captain
you got it you got it oh yeah i do oh
what a talent i know
at some point
we're gonna get good at this at some
point okay and spinning it oh
anything oh that's what that powers
wait
did that do anything
yeah if you
turning that made the whole thing on the
right go oh we've done clipping oh
i see good eye cap unclipping
oh yeah look at this
i have gotten good
good i believe
good job
oh yeah oh god i'm shaking from the
strain
in space no one can hear you shake i'm
assuming i'm doing this all the way and
it's not gonna crush my body like a
grape
why what it just sounds like a bunch of
seagulls
yeah
oh
it's making all one thorough unit
ah
did you calibrate that that engine
why did i plug that out by a stupid
accident i don't know why did you
i don't know oh why captain
captain doesn't need his reasons you're
right it's captaining i'm sorry
oh [ __ ]
it's all good cabin it's all good i
don't know which way is which is so
counterintuitive to what my brain wants
to do this is prepping us for when we
eventually get sent to space which they
def i slam my head in an antenna
i might be dead they're definitely going
to send us the space i sent it outside
oh i didn't realize i could grab this
middle part okay this is on
i think this is the automated [ __ ]
machine from the diagram
finally
did you sync up that signal captain
i don't know which hand is which
oh that's way more helpful actually
you unplugged it
wow
and i'm going to send this up to you
okay
wait i'm ready for it no it's plugged in
captain you can't set you just unplugged
it we didn't calibrate the second
antenna signal capture
everything okay why are you able to grab
the cake the captain why am i the
captain i don't know you have the orange
jumpsuit
wow thank you all you got to do is kind
of like flong him at him yeah i'm
thinking maybe it's like we start up top
and then we go work our way down why
would that be the thing that we do
because i just decided that you never
did you didn't calibrate the second
one
why would this be the way that you would
go to three before you would go to two
because the way the daisy chaining's
gonna work means that it's gonna happen
okay just because you call something a
daisy chain doesn't mean that's what it
is yeah i think that one's stuck oh
there's another cable
uh
yes i'll get it captain oh yeah it's
right next to me well i mean there's
another one over here too captain i mean
it's not that's not the only one okay
whatever we all got cables okay
is that solid snake is that
jacksepticeye first upload solid snake
wow
eat that scab oh the strain i'm like
captain america captain america
oh take your shirt off
okay come on
i'm just holding on because i don't want
to die yeah best not to i'd say okay
yeah oh yeah i gotta i really gotta move
the sticks in the opposite directions
that's really thrilled yeah when it
works then it just totally makes sense
and i just can't get it to work
consistently yeah all right
are our uh days chains erect uh what now
i knew i i knew i knew what a daisy
chain was
okay there's more we gotta plug this in
yeah hang on gotta plug this one in
gavin who you okay okay okay
is this is this really interesting to
watch us do
definitely
come
on oh no it hasn't failed me
yet
it failed me
oh oh god oh oh oh no oh no
i'm not doing it the switch goes
unfucking i'm trying no not destruction
hell i can't i can't captain my way out
of this one hey i got it and
[Applause]
back we okay if left arm needs to pull
okay
i've reversed the direction
oh the polarity oh
[Music]
god
why is this so difficult i'm trying not
to grab onto this cable because this
cable being grabbed onto ruins
everything
i'm just trying to put a [ __ ] cable
in go in the [ __ ] hole
okay got the cable in you're powered
you're powered captain i know i'm not
i'm [ __ ] oh god i hit the wrong
button that's okay captain that's okay
we all make mistakes go in
wow
it wasn't powered so it wasn't like
magnetizing like it normally does all
right cabin
so so captain you say we gotta send it
all the way down first
i reckon
all right
i don't know why i reckon but i reckon i
don't either but i've stopped
questioning things since i left the
church in newton
so uh him and all his lies yeah
it's goddamn lies i'm not gonna be a
newton apologist
uh i've once again made the mistake of
trying to
pull it
oh how do i get around this goddamn
thing
what the [ __ ] does this work
why does my monkey brain make me wanna
do do
oh my god i'm so
upset what did you do no nothing it's
what i haven't done i can't pull this
thing and i can't pull my fat ass around
it
oh please i'm just hoping that the laws
of nature are just gonna take over on
their own okay okay okay i've gotten
around it i've gotten around it captain
i've gotten around it
i'm sending it you're no no no i'm i got
it i'm the [ __ ] greatest
non-newtonian that's ever existed what
did you do
i plugged the thing into the hole
oh good captain good uh
how'd that help us
uh because the power works now
okay
i just you know
excuse me for critical thinking
you know that's not my strong suit but i
just feel like since it's already down
here we might as well calibrate it down
here at first black talk i'm sorry
captain i didn't mean to like that have
you you can say
you know i don't know it you know funny
i don't know
i don't know what newton said i don't
listen to newton i ain't never dead
never did oh god
you're one of those newtonians no no no
no hold on
that's why you couldn't move this thing
the whole delta hold hold on okay
i mean if you think about it you know if
you tony and brain well okay if you do a
thing and then something else happens of
equal value you know there's some logic
in that ah me and my machine are leaving
okay
with the power of orientation oh
that actually helped a lot
it's fascinating how that works
if only i could stop grabbing cables
uh captain
where are you going yup
i'm going all the way to the top baby
okay
there's more
see now plug that bad [ __ ] in oh wait
no i got it
you go okay i don't know why i think
that it does it this way i just thought
gamer logic was that you start from the
end and work your way back
yeah you know i've been gaming a long
time that's also not my logic
so
oh you would say that i think i've
discovered why you're bad at games
captain that it kinks don't you see me
look at me go
only you can get the [ __ ] arm out of
the way okay oh it was plugged in for
just a moment there we go
are you plugged in captain yep
captain yeah now i know do the the thing
what
what do i do
i don't
know
this was tethered for a reason why was
this tethered there's a plug on the
other side
you see it flashing
uh right hand side that big blue thing i
don't know if that's a plug but
i'm doing it okay turning this
is the signal getting better um
no
oh it will
it's actually getting worse uh
oh it'll get better wait what is this
how does that thing go in i think that's
just an object i know it's shining
yeah but i don't think it's a plug i
think it's just a thing
i'm going to get it all right captain
[Music]
look at me
oh i'm about arena off the
stairs i don't think that's a good idea
but
oh no [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i got it
i'm the best
uh
i hate everything about what i've set us
up for
that's all right cabinets all right hey
it's about the friends you make along
the way
are we friends well not right now but we
could be whoo
it's a collectible oh
oh [ __ ] that
i like collectibles
oh
come here okay how the [ __ ] do i get
this back in
uh good question captain good question
all right that is the wrong way to
orient that
captain needs help captain needs help
i'm calling captain don't you worry
don't you worry captain
i am right around the corner ready and
willing
okay i just need to grab another what
arm is doing this
oh there we go oh
oh i crushed my hand oh yeah you bumped
me you bumped me
you bumped me
captain
[Music]
you got this
okay i'll swim sending a collectible
your way i'm going back to my roots of
the sacred sperm
huh we're getting to believe
there is no sperm
there is no apple
into the sperm oh
oh if i grab this and throw it in the
opposite oh yeah no that's newton talk
that would never work
okay
it's gone let it go you know what
sacrificing yourself to the void of
space and peace
this loyalty
captain i'm gonna be honest with you
yeah
newton's right
oh [ __ ] no wait no he wasn't now you're
dead and wrong
no no no please there's gotta be way
hey
ho no it did it gave me enough momentum
flap your way back newton was right
newton be praised
but there's no door cause newton didn't
invent those
[Applause]
that's so much worse than what you did
the first time oh
it's okay i'll send a signal your way
i'm oh it worked i have you in my in my
signal bubble hang on
oh
no that's not good no
oh oh no
oh
how did i do this i'm safe on the ship
i'm safe on the ship newton was wrong
newton was wrong
[Music]
hey
the problem is that you're swaying side
to side but your your backwards momentum
is still going in the right direction no
no no no no no no i'm coming back in oh
i sure wish i could see what the number
was
no i'm coming back
this
the loss it's gone he's back ah
he
he's like a fish in an aquarium ah
i'm like a sperm in a womb
i was right there
or a butthole i guess
sperm can be anywhere these days i don't
know how this makes sense
how did i start going this way
the hell happened
space doesn't make sense man it's just
up there
i want to go newtonian
never
i won't go to newton land
i want a brighter than newton coaster
oh
god i'm just orbiting you that's all i'm
doing
did you complete the objective yet
captain no because you don't want to
move the other thing to get the signal
we need to come in my turning of this
with the turning of that turn
what am i turning it's up and down and
left and right it's
[Applause]
the signal box needs to match up up and
down with my turn off the lefty right
when you did the first signal was it all
about moving the dish or was did you
also have to move the box i moved the
box as well oh
okay i should have stayed inside then
yeah i mean that was kind of a given
regardless
well you know how adventurous i am
oh i sure do okay i've learned if you
just kind of inchworm your way around
things turn out better for some reason
okay okay they don't turn out better
when there's a freaking door okay so i'm
one of those buyers and you're the other
one i don't know which is which okay
i think i'm the flat one
so i think we got to get them to sync up
okay all right cap
i'm
not on it but i'm almost on it
you can grab the middle bar oh you're
right
okay
so i don't know if i'm supposed to match
you or you're supposed to match me
okay i don't know cam
i'm just a flag in the wind i can only
go so far i just unplugged i don't know
if we're supposed to move this thing i
think
i think it
then okay
here's the thought captain
what if because the other
dishes aren't synced up this one isn't
giving you anything
so
if i'm reading what you're saying
if i'm picking up your signal per se
it's that
i was wrong
well that's a bold statement i
i'm i may have been wrong
about what
um
[Music]
did newton ah there you go newton be
praised i always knew his glorious
his glorious
thoughts
may the apple be within you
appleby
this is not getting me back to oh you
just gotta go in the opposite direction
it's so [ __ ] obvious
equal and opposite oh
does this thing go out oh yeah jerking
it it extended a little oh wait
it's extending oh that's what you were
missing
you were right i was right all along
oh newton
[Music]
okay i'll plug you back in captain hold
on hold on hold on now if only i could
figure out how to get my lefty on this
oh you're getting closer you're getting
closer extend it a little more more
erect stroke it struck the shaft
i don't know how tickle the boomer
wait i think i need to turn the dish now
yeah yeah you're projecting i see a
gooshing signal oh this should be an
olympic sport finally a medal for me
you're getting closer you're getting
closer you're getting closer how do arms
work
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i got this all you got
to do is kick
all you got to do is kick i really don't
think the kicking does much
oh you
you've been wrong all this time and now
you're going to question me you're right
have you recap i'm sorry i
oh
you got off it a little bit
you're getting closer now the amplitude
needs to increase which i think is the
extension of the thing but you stay
right there i'll go i'll go let little
sperm handle this uh let little sperm
somehow get stuck on my own arm are you
sure you don't just have to move the box
like down a little and then we're good i
don't think it's about moving the box i
don't maybe let me you know that's fine
that's right i'm throwing out a lot of
demands a lot of accusations
no it's not the box
okay yeah that's good that's good that's
good let me try to stroke this shaft
let me try to oh graceful
hang on now you gotta you gotta let go
no
oh
so yeah it's safety protocols they died
in space camp
yeah remember how they gave us tethers
last time and then this time they're
just like well
have fun
yeah i am having fun captain i am oh
here we go you're gonna have to there
you go there you go there you go kick
kick for the love of god man kick
oh yeah
oh he's such a good kicker
oh oh oh waves they're blasting him away
okay okay okay yeah what's the radiation
level coming out of this thing
all right wait no is it just that one or
do we have to do
it does the middle go out as well i
think that's max
no it's gonna be a little more
this is just definitely the amplitude
okay yeah let me grab the middle one let
me see about that ooh
hold on
oh oh
oh no it comes out more it comes out
more hang on and i just gotta okay
that's yeah you just gotta swap hands
but it's very tricky okay or
oh yeah stroke it stroke it and not
stroke it what if i kick off broken
little sperm stroke it hang on
oh my god it just i literally
my brain keeps continually thinking that
it's different than what it is i'm
rotating
there you go straight up
this is good i'm not going to stroke it
not down
okay
okay if you go down there's nowhere to
go but
what if i here and then
okay what if i grab a little higher
a little higher no no no no no no no
come on come on come on
oh come on
come on come on come on oh my god
come on
there okay
and then
extend out right in the face
right in the face
yeah let me hang on here
oh
okay
oh so close
are you close oh i'm close we did it
yeah
is that the right orientation oh oh
we did it
what was the [ __ ] point of all the
other ones along the way to
calibrate them also
captain
oh
what do you mean oh
this is all newton's fault did you think
they just placed all those other ones
for decorations
i thought i thought it was like a signal
chain you know start with the with the
source like the signal going out and
then work your way back to calibrate the
rest of them
wait what then why did we call it
the main one calibrated oh we calibrated
one before this one no no
no
we've never calibrated anything
oh no captain i think your space stupid
no i'm regular stupid in space
ah common misconception
all right i'm going down this way
there's a door somewhere
sure is cabin don't worry i'll bring the
device
i'm space walking my way out of this
[ __ ] look i thought we couldn't
calibrate those until we had the main
calibration done i don't know i don't
follow that logic but i understand that
you thought it someone will back me up
right guys all right coming down
nope okay and for some reason i'm jammed
in between it again how does this keep
happening i don't understand how
oh my god i'm so mad i'm
orienting i'm so mad i'm orienting
i just
wish things made sense i just wish they
did and i know they do but i wish that
things made sense i wish that things
made sense okay this is also ah see how
this is an extendo boober that would
have taught us
that we need to do extendo boober the
final one
see i've played many games in my time
and i know my way around i just thought
you couldn't get a signal out of this
one until the main one was off and going
i you keep saying those words they don't
make sense i just
look my brain works on a different level
look i'm not the one who got lost in
space and didn't know how to kick i got
back
all right i'm gonna go out no i'm not
no i'm not
i've forgotten what hands or hands again
what arm is arm
oh god i just was gonna do it
that didn't help
all right i'm going out
oh
okay and then
i'm gonna do
is i'm orient
no no no not disorient not disorient you
should be able to use both arms in this
one yeah hang on anchor yourself uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like
[Music]
no not that i can't oh my god oh my god
yeah it's
here
oh
so extended
hold
i got it ah
[Music]
looks like i was right all along
well i'll blow this whole space station
up i'll blow it all up please do we got
one more cabin why are you having
trouble with this i don't know
it's just
[Music]
bye hold on i'm coming
oh god [ __ ] [ __ ] stop were you having
trouble
no problem
no
out of all the space idiots that i had
to get stuck with they put me with you
yeah well they put me with me too so how
do you think i feel i have to live with
this stupid like stuff makes sense for
like five seconds and then somehow it
all just doesn't yes yes i know
you see my legs
you can jam did it
you just get changed
i don't know okay i'm going to hold it
i'm going to hold it you go around it
okay
oh
yeah you get
oh there oh [ __ ] rope dart it's a rope
dart that's what it's called that's what
it's called that's what it's called all
right you got this
i don't know i think i'm grabbing my own
hip and uh
nice nice nice all right
you got this i'm heading there
all right i'll race ya
erase me he says
oh [ __ ]
i almost had it okay what's the what's
the dealio on this one
pull right
huh rotate it oh
and almost there a little more a little
more a little more
i don't think there is more a little
more is there more a little more extend
it hey
no
oh oh too far too far too far
there we go
build that bar baby
bam done
ah bring the data tower online oh cool
okay
oh so many towers
we did this
i'm proud of we
it could have been done in half the time
well we're not done you have to oh
god mission control
just stick it on your suit ugh
okay
i'm thinking we don't need to bring this
thing back so uh i'm not even gonna
bother with it i doubt it you do
challenges new challenges are available
cabin we can do it even harder than we
did
captain's in a bit of a situation
i just hate
i just hate enjoy i just hate this thing
i hate it
i hate this thing
we're unplugged why are you taking it
with us i have no choice captain this is
what the voice inside of me says to do
and i'm
right of course
of course
of course my body's in the way if i tear
off my body
then i'd never get in
i just take my suit off it won't get in
the way
all right come back to us come back to
us i'm coming back oh
i almost had it back i almost had it you
did good you did good i know i know i
know you did real good thank you you too
youtube i'm proud of you i'm proud of
you
[Music]